For this house, I wanted to make each room very special and different from the next.
When curating the collection of art for this house,...
...I wanted to highlight emerging artists from underrepresented communities.
I was able to get really creative with argyle design.
I had such an amazing time designing this house with them.
This is actually my reception room, kind of formal living room.
I wanted it to feel very maximalist and creative.
There's like this amazing piece by Hannah Epstein called White Pumps.
I love my yellow couch.
I think it brightens up the room.
I love the rug from House of Hackney.
We've got this statue in the corner that I think just gives it a really chic touch.
The chandelier in this room is designed by Moooi and it's called Meshmatics,...
...and I think what's really beautiful about this...
...is it brings a soft touch to the rest of the room.
Literally, the purpose of this room is just to give it that wow factor...
...when people walk into the house.
I literally spend no time in here, but my dogs love it.